Now this wasn't just a linear function. This was a cubic function. And its
inverse is the cubed root of x minus 1. Now that's great work if you found this
solution. Again, we'll start by making f of x by y, our output. Now we're going
to switch x and y. Now we have a function that we can solve for y in order to
find the inverse. Now our goal is to get y alone, so first we'll subtract 1
from both sides of the equation, to get x minus 1 equals y cubed. Now we need
to undo this power of 3. Well, I know cube-roots undo a third power. So taking
the cube-root of both sides of the equation, I'll have one y equal to the
cube-root of x minus one. Now, keep in mind this is our inverse function, so we
take y and replace it with f-inverse of x. Here's our solution.